all right joining us now pft p.m from
the barn a guy who chris sims has pegged
as the top safety in the 2020 draft
class he is the university of
minnesota's antoine winfield jr hello
antoine how are you i'm doing well how
about yourself i'm doing well it makes
me feel really old
to say antoine winfield jr because it
feels like your dad was just playing the
other day
yes crazy he really just was you know he
only retired about what
five six years ago and um you know it's
crazy because i've been getting that a
lot everybody's saying like they feel
old because they either watched my dad
play uh coached them or uh recruited him
coming out of college so it's been crazy
you know sometimes the kid doesn't want
to do the thing that dad does doesn't
think it's cool not interested in
anything dad's interested in when did
you get the football bug and decide
that's what you wanted to do even though
dad did it
yeah at an early age um you know i play
football ever since i could walk
and um i just remember uh being out in
the backyard working out with my dad
doing things like that with him and then
i just remember like one day i'm like i
want to do this and then i'm watching
his career over time this is something i
definitely want to do with my life
when did you know
that you had it right that your dad's
jeans had made it through to you and you
had special skills not just like i like
football i like running around with my
dad you actually had something that
would take you to the level you're at
yeah i would say um playing football in
uh college is where i really felt like i
could do this at the next level um you
know i did my high school years and then
um that transition from high school to
college was wasn't that bad for me and i
knew um once i played during college and
saw like what the talent level was and
things like that i felt like i could uh
really make an impact at the next level
i saw a great video on your twitter page
of you and your dad playing when you
were very very little
how old were you and do you remember the
moment when you realized if this went
sideways i can take dad if i have to
um in the video i was about two years
old but i feel like i could take my dad
when i was about a
junior senior in high school
um i remember one thing that we did we
raced uh back when i was probably like
16 or 17 and i beat him in a race and
that's all you heard from that uh
conversation you know we're super
competitive so we compete on pretty much
anything but
i think i could take him around my
junior senior year in high school
do you remember the look in his eyes
though when he realized that i remember
it for me and my dad when
i could just see like it's that it's
that primal alpha male you can see the
look where he's surrendering do you
remember that look yeah oh of course you
know i got it it's like it's
my head um yeah i remember he just you
know he couldn't really say too much
since i beat him so um it was just funny
just you know go out there and embarrass
them a little bit
how much of your tackling skills are
natural because your dad has them and
how much of it is from studying guys
like your dad
yeah um i would say uh it's 50 50. um
you know it comes naturally but you also
got to work on it and i would say um i
worked on my attack within practice you
know we had a tackle circuit pretty much
every day um in practice so i feel like
it was a lot of practicing you know
technique and form tackling which
account
abilities
what's the best advice dad's ever given
you about this game
yeah the best advice he's given me is
just to be myself um also that's the
best thing you know
be unique don't try to be like anybody
else and pretty much just give it
everything that you have
and how hard is it to do that when you
see people you want to pattern yourself
after you've got some tyrant matthew
you've got some antoine winfield senior
how do you find a way to craft your own
identity when there are guys you
naturally are going to want to pattern
yourself after yeah yeah you know i want
to it's not necessarily i want to be
just like a specific player it's i want
to use what i think their great aspects
are into my game and kind of create my
own game if that makes sense i want to
be myself but if i see something that
this player is doing that i like i want
to try to include that into my game you
know one of the things patrick mahomes
has talked about that helped make him
comfortable at the nfl level was being
around in his whole life growing up
being in the clubhouse with his dad his
dad played baseball different
sport but same idea you're around
professional athletes you're not
flustered or blown away or in awe once
you get there how much of that do you
think is going to help you because
you've really been in that same boat and
it wasn't baseball you've been in the
football locker rooms you know what it
feels like what it smells like what it
looks like how much do you think that's
going to help you in the nfl yeah i
think it's going to help a lot um you
know growing up my dad played he always
had players over at the house we would
go to pretty much all the mini camps
that they had in mankato and we were
always around uh some of his teammates
so it's not going to be a big shock when
i go to a team and see
all these players because i'm used to i
grew up that way so um i think it's
gonna help a lot
who is your favorite guy from your dad's
teammates
out of my dad's teammates i would say
uh
vinnie sat
vinnie said we would always put a game
downstairs and um he was always cool and
his also his son used to always come
over with him and i played college
football with his son we played together
at minnesota but um it was just cool to
be able to play with his son after his
scene and my dad played with his dad so
it was a cool experience
i've been watching a lot of your
highlights and you got some really good
ball skills how much thought did you
ever give to playing offense at the
college level instead of defense
i would if i could you know i wanted to
get some little packages in there but i
couldn't do that so i just stick to the
defensive side but i wouldn't mind
playing offense in college
and you look like you're an offensive
player back there with number 11 how'd
you end up wearing number 11
yeah so um
i really got to choose i either wanted
number one or number 11. and um i ended
up just going with number 11. my dad was
also number 11 in college as well so
that's kind of also why i chose that
number
now i i saw when you committed to the
university of minnesota
you had offers from missouri
northwestern and purdue
but none of them ohio state
did you you got a little chip on your
shoulder about not getting an offer from
ohio state your dad's school
um you know i grew up an ohio state fan
you know both my parents went there so i
was raised a buckeye but um you know
there was never really uh any chip on my
shoulder i knew wherever i ended up
going i was gonna do great things so i
was just looking for an opportunity to
play anywhere and you know i just took
my shot i knew i was going to take
advantage of anything that came my way
but given what you accomplished in ohio
state's conference unanimous
all-american the big ten defensive back
of the year
do you at some level
think hey the buckeyes missed the boat
they could have had me and uh for
whatever reason they didn't want me and
they may regret it now
yeah they may have uh regretted it but
you know i wouldn't change the thing i
went
up to minnesota i'm playing uh my years
there
hey what what do you
what do you do best on the football
field what's the one thing that you can
say this is my identity this is what i
do better than anyone else who's coming
out into the draft that plays safety
yeah i would say my ability to create
takeaways and that's the most important
thing you know playing football being
able to give that offense uh the ball
back gives you more opportunity to win
so um i feel like my ability to create
takeaways is one of my biggest aspects
to my game
and how does that happen for you is it
an instinct that happens in the moment
is it film study that allows you to
maybe get a sense of when the ball is
going to be in the air and how the guy's
going to throw it how you're going to be
able to break on it how do you get to
the point where that ability to generate
takeaways specifically interceptions
become such a good trait
yeah film study and practice i would say
film study because you got to study your
opponent um you got to know who the
quarterback's main targets are who's
getting the ball how are they carrying
the ball um
where's the quarterback looking when
he's throwing and things like that as
far as film study because you got to be
one step ahead of the offenses at every
time and i would say doing it in
practice you know my goal was to create
one takeaway a day and um you know the
things that you do in practice you do in
the game and so that kind of translated
over to uh game situations and where i
would make those big plays is because i
would make them in practice
what would you say when you have that
takeaway in practice were you a talker
would you bark at the quarterback or
whoever it was you took the ball away
from
yeah sometimes it depends on the mood i
was in but yeah i would definitely talk
a little trash up there
so as the draft is approached i saw that
you have spoken with the vikings and
this is a crazy
different environment than we would have
had in a normal year you would have had
visits you would add private workouts
who all have you had this kind of a
conversation with over the past few
weeks
yeah um it's been a few uh off the top
of my head
um
chiefs
um
patriots
um
who else titans uh
books
it's been a few more i can't think of a
name of all of them but all the time i
hear those with a few
do you keep a little wish list of the
teams that you hope draft you when the
process starts next week
you know what i don't have a preference
you know i'm i'm just excited to see
where i end up going no matter where i
go i'm going to be excited with whoever
chooses me
in a weird situation to be in though
where you know there's these 32
different possibilities i mean it's like
it's like uh playing a lottery game or
pulling a name out of a hat you have no
idea what it's going to be until it
happens i mean you may have some idea
based on who's shown interest in you but
still even then plenty of times a team
will draft a guy that has shown no
interest in whatsoever exactly you never
know who could pick you up and um you
know it's different because you know
being recruited coming out of high
school you got to choose where you go
now it's you're taking a back seat and
um you know you're letting these other
teams choose and dictate where you go so
that's the price
it's exciting but it's um it's unique
hey antoine i'm going to go there since
you led the way i get accused all the
time of having a crusade against the
draft because i think the guys should be
able to pick where they play in the nfl
just like they get to play where they
play in college do you think about that
at all right now man if i wanted to play
for the vikings they got a needed safety
i could go play for the vikings off to
go through all this stuff do you wish at
some level that you could pick where you
go next
um you know i i don't wish you know i
wanted i want i wanted to be in somebody
else's hands because
um i feel like that's that's the
uniqueness behind it and that's like the
excitement is that you don't know where
you're going to end up going i feel like
that's a big part of this you know
process um especially on draft day like
it's just a weird experience but it's
going to be fun
your name's on the list of the 58 guys
who will be participating in the draft
from home set the scene for me who's
going to be there what are you going to
be doing you're going to have the camera
on that the nfl sends you as you're
waiting to be drafted give me give us an
idea of what it's going to look like
that night
yeah i'm just going to be at home with
my family we're just going to be in the
living room just hanging out and
watching the draft
will you put the suit on that you would
have worn to the draft or are you just
going to be casual yeah i'm just gonna
go with a more casual look um you know
since i'm at home might as well be
casual and be comfortable so no no suit
this time
well antoine we very much look forward
to seeing where you end up when the
draft gets rolling next week we wish you
all the best congratulations on your
success it's great talking to you
hopefully we can do this again once we
know which of those 32 teams calls your
name next week we're sure thank you very
much
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports